[Music]
one night I got really drunk in a bar
and I got talking to a guy like a really
old guy and his kid that just had a
child so he was like he showed me a
picture of his grandchild and I we were
talking and it got like we got really
drunk and it got quite flirty and
without any inhibitions I I went for it
and it was the best sex I've ever had
how am I supposed to figure this out I
am NOT turned on by guys my age I am
really turned on by guys that could
basically be my granddad at least my dad
over than my dad sometimes I can't tell
anyone and like if I want to have kids
how does that work because I just feel
this I like I feel it inside myself and
I can't get rid of it I don't really
know what to do it's hard
when I'm having sex with my girlfriend I
I think of men but but I'm not gay um I
mean I love my girlfriend and I never
had sex with men and that's the thing
that I don't I don't want to do I don't
believe that love is is a sexual thing
although sex is is a big part of
anybody's relationship but that's not it
it's not the biggest thing right so I
don't think I'm I'm gay I just think
that that is something that needs to be
explained and I and I can't explain I
just it just can't I've got a boyfriend
at the moment we've only been seeing
each other for a couple of months or so
and we have sex and it is good but it's
just like how it was when I was with you
know in my previous relationships it's
just it's just normal it's not very
exciting at all and I can't orgasm with
him without watching this particular
porn so that the porn that I do enjoy
watching it's it shows quite graphic
scenes of of of torture and and yeah
people in pain and it does yeah it turns
me on and but I haven't yet told him
that
I find it not really difficult the
thought of speaking to him about it is
really yes it's really hard for me and
I'm not sure if I'm gonna be able to
bring myself around to doing it
I don't know I'm going to explain this
so much it may be age I don't really
know but I have a terrible job getting
erections it gets to my mind it really
makes me really makes me worry I mean
the things I see people do or I hear of
people doing it I'd love to be able to
do myself when you get out of it the
desires are still with you you still
have them but your body just won't let
you do anything about them
I'm in a relationship with a woman we've
been together for a while as long term
is serious we're in love
everything is great really there's
something that has come up recently
which is causing friction between us I
have a fantasy if you would of being a
schoolgirl again and being taken off
into the woods by a group of men I want
him to rip my clothes off I want him to
fight over me I want to see the passion
in their eyes I want I want to be
outside I want to be unsafe I'm gonna be
powerless and I I can't get this out of
my head it's become an obsession
I don't even find the unattractive so I
really don't I don't even understand
where this is coming from I just don't
know what to do because when me and my
girlfriend tried to make love she knows
that there's something else on my mind
it frustrates me that I can't be present
with her and I don't know what to do
[Music]
thank you for watching liking and
subscribing if you want more why not
visit us in person and attend a class or
take a look at our shop at the link on
your screen now